le parti vert annonce son cadre
financier qui prévoit 65 milliards de
dollars de nouvelles dépenses dès la
première année
le parti prévoit une hausse du déficit
34 milliards mais le retour au déficit
zéro en 2023 24 le parti vert prévoit de
toucher des revenus supplémentaires de
40 à 50 milliards par année grâce à une
hausse d'impôt des entreprises
une taxe sur les transactions
financières la fin de l'exonération de
l'impôt sur le gain en capital et une
taxe sur la fortune
le parti vert propose la gratuité pour
les frais de scolarité postsecondaire
c'est plus de 16 milliards de dollars un
régime national d'assurance médicaments
30 milliards et puis une taxe sur les
boissons sucrées et le transfert de 1%
de la tps à l'infrastructure municipale
c'est 8 à 10 milliards de dollars
alors tout un programme qu'on va
analyser avec pierre avec luc jolicoeur
voilà luc jolicoeur qui est candidat du
parti vert du québec monsieur jeu de
dire bonsoir bonsoir alors 65 milliards
de dollars de nouvelles dépenses et une
hausse de 20% du budget de l'état est ce
que est ce que ça c'est plus de faire ça
est-ce que c'est réaliste de proposer 65
milliards la première année dans la
mesure où il ya des sources de revenus
qui sont identifiés et c'est le cas
c'est tout à fait possible et on arrive
assez rapidement à l'équilibré
budgétaire avec de nouvelles de
nouvelles sources de revenus et ça ça
serait du pot par une augmentation de la
fonction publique il ya beaucoup de
dépenses qui sont des d où est venue
parler d'investissements mais qui vont
aider transfert aux municipalités ou aux
provinces et aussi de l'argent qui va
pouvoir être perçue directement par les
canadiens évidemment on parle du
programme pour les médicaments qui est
qui qui est quelque chose d'important
l'assurance médicaments c'est 30
milliards par année
la gratuité pour les frais de scolarité
postsecondaire ces 16 milliards
ce qui est étonnant c'est gros plus
grosses mesures ne sont pas
nécessairement des initiatives vertes
vous y allez sur des mesures sociales
importantes pourquoi c'est comme ça
qu'on ne visions
globale des choses d'abord le la crise
climatique est au coeur de notre de
notre plateforme c'est dès le début de
la plate forme mais on va on veut
atteindre nos objectifs on se fixe les
objectifs les plus ambitieux 60% d'ici
2030 et on va le faire avec la taxe sur
le carbone et le ski va être générée
comme taxe carbone va être retournée au
canadien bon c'est combien la taxe sur
le carbone va monter à combien bains en
savoie et va évoluer progressivement
dans les âpres et variés 1 100 et 200
dollars nous on est à 20 23
exactement oui et ça va ça va être
retournée sous forme de dividendes ou
aux canadiens de façon une forme à tout
le monde donc ça ça va aider les gens et
est ce que je veux souligner aussi dont
on oublie souvent de parler c'est que
l'achat de pétrole c'est une dépense
considérable
donc les canadiens pour diminuer leurs
achats de pétrole les entreprises aussi
donc ça va savoir générer de d&d
économique je comprends qu'on rend bien
mais je regarde frais de scolarité par
exemple gratuite et ses 16 milliards en
2020 21
je vous disais l'assurance médicaments
c'est 30 milliards
les transferts de point de pourcentage à
tps aux municipalités ces 10 milliards
de dollars et quand on regarde
transports en commun balaya 100 millions
pour un fonds permanent pour le
transport en commun local
l'infrastructure cyclable de 100
millions c'est des petits montants on se
serait attendu
il me semble dans le la plateforme du
parti vert à des investissements massifs
dans des initiatives bain par rapport
aux dunes york va transférer aux
municipalités on s'attend que les
municipalités utilisent cet argent là
pour le transport en commun donc et
aussi pour améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique des bâtiments
mais nous on veut travailler avec avec
les municipalités
on veut des villes plus agréable pour
les canadiens ont vu réduire autant que
possible les déplacements en automobile
on a aussi des choses qui ont prévu pour
via rail des dépenses de fonctionnement
mais aussi de nouveaux achats la même
chose pour postes canada on veut
électrifier les véhicules de postes est
ce que la pensée magique dans vos
projections de revenus vous dit le taux
d'imposition des sociétés on veut faire
passer de 15 à 21 pour ça qu'ils ont
montré ça nous rapporterait 13 milliards
par année
est-ce que vous avez calculé l'effet
décélérateur sur l'économie la mobilité
de ses entreprises ou des mieux nantis
qui pourrait dire un instant moi je dois
payer de taxes supplémentaires aux états
unis en baisse les impôts puis vous vous
nous les montre autre chose je comprends
très bien votre question de travailler
avec le directeur parlementaire du
budget pour arriver à ces chiffres là
donc ça c'est le premier élément de
réponse
l'autre chose c'est qu'on pense que
l'économie du canada est très
compétitive à danse à ce que les
entreprises étrangères peuvent
s'installer ici notamment en cause la
qualité de la main d'oeuvre et ça ça
passe beaucoup par le système
d'éducation et on touche un très petit
nombre de personnes
avec ces mesures là et on est convaincu
que ces personnes là vont rester ici
parce que ils veulent contribuer au
développement économique du canada et il
aime bien
ici de tous les avantages qu'on peut
retirer de vivre au canada en termes de
soins de santé d'éducation
justement pourquoi prenez-vous un
engagement du déficit zéro dans cinq
heures pourquoi c'est important compte
tenu des investissements importants des
gros changements que vous voulez faire
pourquoi vous vous mettez cet objectif
d'arriver absolument l'équilibré
budgétaire
c'est une excellente question mais c'est
sûr que c'est c'est notre objectif parce
que on nous fait beaucoup de reproches
de poids est réaliste mais je pense
qu'on démontre avec 50 financiers lors
qu'il ya des sources de revenus
possibles on peut équilibrer la
fiscalité l'impôt sur la fortune par
exemple les banques qui font des gros
profits
les transactions financières qui vont
être taxés on parle d'un montant de 18
milliards
à ce titre la sas a aucun impact sur les
canadiens ordinaires tout ça et est donc
c'est c'est faisable ce conclave est
acceptée par les gens les mieux nantis
impôt sur la fortune par les entreprises
d'arvert 21 pour ça que vous allez allez
chercher vos moteurs puis vous arrivé au
difficile 095 en tant que c'est
équitable qui on vise pas les petites
entreprises
on pense ça va être accepté parce que ça
existe ailleurs dans le monde mais c'est
un peu ça le problème souvent on on
hésite parce qu'on se dit on devrait pas
faire ça et finalement mais c'est
d'autres qui qui prennent les devants
même le québec quand les devants en
entassant netflix et le gouvernement du
canada et états est à la traîne
donc il ya des mesures qui vont se
mettre en place dans d'autres pays on
vit dans ce moment une urgence
climatique et on doit prendre soin de
notre population et pour ça il faut
faire des investissements majeurs bien
monsieur lequel on s'arrête ici merci
beaucoup merci merci bien
rdi économie présente d'ailleurs le
débat économique de la campagne fédérale
le 1er octobre à 18 heures heure de
l'est édition spéciale d'une heure avec
un représentant du parti vert peut-être
monsieur jolicoeur et d'autres
représentants des autres partis
également